the american nation
cannot must not and will not permit the
establishment of another communist
government
this is called a cavendish banana it's
the most common banana on earth it's
probably the one that you have in your
kitchen right now it's definitely the
one you see in the grocery store this
banana was created in a fancy-looking
house in england
yes created and yes in england kind of
weird bananas aren't from england
they're originally from asia and there
are thousands of different kinds of
bananas
so how did this banana the cavendish
that was created in england become the
banana that you eat today well the
answer to that is not so simple you have
to understand the story of bananas which
yes is something
we're diving into today it's a story
filled with predatory corporations and
geopolitics and american imperialism and
disease and
really some amazing marketing it
explains how corporations can grow so
big that they begin to act like
governments like dictators
and it explains why this banana the
cavendish the one you know and love
might not exist soon the world's most
popular banana may be on the verge of
extinction oh and while i was diving
deep into this i discovered that there's
a better tasting banana out there one
that isn't supposed to exist anymore but
i got my hands on some and yes they're
better so buckle up this is the ef'd up
history of bananas
we're pausing this story really quick
because i just need to thank the sponsor
of today's video which is stamps.com a
service that i have used for now several
years long before they came to sponsor a
video so it's kind of cool a few years
ago i became independent which meant i
had to start running my own business i
quickly realized that running a business
means shipping things a lot i was
shipping hard drives with footage i was
shipping gear and lenses i was going to
the post office a bunch which is kind of
my nightmare so i googled like what's
the best way to not go to the post
office and stamps.com came up stamps.com
is all of the things that the post
office does but in your office or house
i can ship packages and letters
for less cost from the comfort of this
studio in fact right behind me is my
whole like stamps.com setup got a fancy
scale so i literally put the package on
the scale it tells me how much it is it
plugs into my computer and i type in the
address of where i'm sending it and it
spits out a shipping label that i then
print with my label printer and i put it
on the package and then i put it at my
front door and it gets taken away by the
mail person like it's the easiest thing
in the world and i'm very grateful that
i discovered it stamps.com is saving
lots of businesses time and money it has
certainly saved me a lot of time and
money which is why i'm really grateful
that they're supporting this channel and
sponsoring today's video you can get
four weeks of this for free if you want
to just try it out there's a link in my
description stamps.com johnny harris if
you sign up you'll get this free trial
plus some free postage and a digital
scale you'll get one of those scales
which is incredibly helpful there's no
long-term commitment or contracts just
go to stamps.com johnny harris to start
your trial get a free scale and some
postage and never have to go to the post
office again okay so bananas are from
southeast asia but like 400 years ago
europeans were taking over the world and
the portuguese brought bananas over to
the americas a few hundred years later
an american sailor was in jamaica and he
found this funny-looking exotic yellow
fruit and money started flashing in his
eyes he started selling bananas to
americans who quickly loved this new
fruit bananas were trending people were
talking about it so then fast forward to
nearly the end of the 1800s
and you have the world's fair where all
the people show up and show off their
new technology at the fair you've got
this guy alexander graham bell who's
showing up with his cute little new
invention that's about to change the
world
but another crowd favorite at the expo
was the banana
yes bananas were equally as impressive
as the telephone at the world's fair the
banana business started booming in the
united states much of these bananas
flowing in from new york city the port
there was dubbed banana docks for a
while because of so much fruit import so
now you have all these americans eating
this sweet creamy delicious fruit and
throwing the slippery peels onto the
street it got so bad that the police
commissioner at the time
oh god i can't get away from this guy
teddy roosevelt once again i swear i get
into any story i like start to research
it and it's like yeah and then there's
american imperialism and it's like teddy
roosevelt like shows up anyway so teddy
roosevelt the police commissioner starts
putting a fine on people for throwing
their banana peels on the sidewalk
like this isn't just like a silly fake
joke it's like this is a real thing
people slipped on banana peels patrick
banana peel don't what did you say
and you could go to jail for it i mean
look at this there's this new york times
article
documenting teddy roosevelt the police
commissioner speaking to a room of
police captains explaining quote the bad
habits of banana skins and dwelling
particularly on its tendency to toss
people into the air and bring them down
with terrific force on the hard pavement
this was a real issue
okay okay okay banana docs teddy
roosevelt slippery banana peels silly
newspaper articles from the late 1800s
this isn't the story here we're just
getting started this is like bananas
like innocent phase
it's about to heat up let's see how
bananas turned from this
to this
[Applause]
the banana business people in the u.s
realized it was time to ramp up to meet
all of this new demand but instead of
just importing more bananas from say
jamaica or other countries in the
caribbean the banana companies realized
that they needed to control the supply
chain let me explain what i mean by
second by looking at this banana bananas
are
fragile they're soft they spoil in like
a week like this one's like moments away
from spoiling look at those spots to get
this thing from somewhere close to the
equator all the way to new york city and
then into someone's market and then into
somebody's home
all without it being crushed and without
it spoiling is a fragile quick expensive
process and the only way to do it
profitably is to do a lot of it a lot of
bananas
[Music]
the only way to do a lot of bananas is
to control the supply chain so it's like
1900 at this point there's a banana gold
rush happening and there's a bunch of
companies trying to figure out how to
control the supply chain and then they
decided to sort of merge together and
become this one super company called the
united fruit company and their plan for
combining was to control everything
control the supply chain they turned
their attention completely to central
america where they know bananas could
grow abundantly and where oh look at
this the us is thinking about making a
little canal that cuts through this
little narrow strip of land so the
united fruit company is like
that's kind of a nice perk for the
region if anything goes wrong the u.s
could have our backs foreshadowing am i
foreshadowing i'm foreshadowing so yeah
united fruit companies like this region
central america looks like a great
neighborhood to control the supply chain
they wanted to control the people who
worked on the farm by owning their basic
survival needs they wanted to control
the houses they lived in and the stores
they shopped in and what they could buy
they wanted to control the
transportation by building railways so
that they could quickly ship their
product onto ports they wanted to
control the boats and the waterways so
that they could get all of these bananas
from central america to the u.s
before they spoiled they started with
guatemala
pouring tons of investment into
controlling every inch of their supply
chain soon they were the largest company
in guatemala they owned a fifth of the
farmable land in the country they owned
all of the railways and all of the radio
stations and radio infrastructure and by
1901 the government of guatemala
actually hired the united fruit company
to manage the country's postal service
what united fruit was starting to look a
lot like a government and the result was
a lot of happy banana-eating americans
so they kept going they kept expanding
their operations across central america
so now with all of this beautiful
infrastructure and trains and land the
next strategy for making bananas even
more profitable was you guessed it
paying the workers next to nothing oh
and paying them not with real money
a lot of the times united fruit paid
their workers in vouchers these vouchers
could only be used in designated united
fruit commissaries so they're not
actually making real money here so wait
now the united fruit company has its own
currency oh and they also had like a
private navy
93 boats called the great white fleet
then eventually they started using these
boats to like transport people on
cruises these boats were even used
during world war ii
united fruit started to look like a
literal government they had their hands
in everything so much so that they
earned their self the nickname el pulpo
which means the octopus in spanish
meaning they had their tentacles in
everything all over central america the
land the crops the people the
infrastructure and soon enough
government agencies soon these countries
became so dominated by and reliant on
the united fruit company that they were
no longer run by the people or the
governments they were run by american
banana companies who had all the power
and leverage in the world this led to
the nickname banana republic
which is a politically unstable country
whose society is exploited for profit
for one single product in this case
bananas yeah and probably not the best
sort of thing to name your clothing
store after like just a thought but like
who who made that decision united fruit
and other banana companies continued to
grow and control central america
eventually people got tired of this in
1911 honduras was like all right we're
done banana companies like
we're gonna take back our land we can
take it from here these are our
plantations you've gone too far banana
companies didn't like this so they
organized a private army to help
overthrow the government so that they
could put in a president that they liked
who would allow them to keep doing
exactly what they were doing and also
give them a tax break so yeah banana
companies are now overthrowing
governments jeez
this kept happening anytime there was
political dissent or the governments of
these countries started to like step up
and say like no the banana companies
would intervene and guess who had their
back the us military and yes
we're back to teddy roosevelt's
teddy roosevelt
what a guy
here's teddy stomping around the
caribbean with his big stick making sure
that american military and business
interests are protected in honduras
alone the u.s invaded seven times in the
early 1900s
all in the name of protecting these
banana companies and other us interests
from having to face these pesky locals
who were so audacious as to want to run
their own country how dare they if you
remember that at this time the u.s was
starting to get really comfortable with
empire behavior and central america was
at the top of the priority list the
banana companies knew this which allowed
them to feel emboldened to just sort of
do whatever they wanted in the region
okay but this is sort of child's play it
started to get a lot worse in the 1920s
there was a situation in colombia where
a bunch of workers for the united fruit
company decided to stop working and
protest their working conditions they
were asking for a few things like i
don't know working six days a week
instead of seven or getting paid real
money the united fruit company refuses
to negotiate with them and instead goes
to the u.s and says hey usa we've got
these really annoying workers who are
like trying to unionize and trying to
get paid and stuff and it actually
smells a lot like
communism
and the us is like wait what communism
tell me more so then the us threatens to
invade with their marines and squash
this strike if the colombian military
doesn't do something first reminder that
we're not talking about some big
political revolution or rebellion we're
talking about a few workers in a banana
plantation protesting for more humane
conditions and yet this was a priority
for the us government to put pressure on
colombia to fix the situation of course
colombia didn't want to make the u.s
angry so they responded and sent in
their own troops to go put down this
workers strike and they were ordered to
quote spare no ammunition
so on december 5th 1928 these protesters
are in the town square in this town in
colombia and the colombian army shows up
and massacres them men women and
children were killed by their own
military all because an american banana
company didn't want to pay them a decent
wage i mean this is
madness it is madness to think that
these large geopolitical forces were
coming to bear over a banana plantation
this event is called the banana massacre
this didn't stop in 1928. fast forward
to guatemala in the 1950s at this point
the united fruit company el pulpo is
making major profits they own almost 50
percent of the land in guatemala
tax-free but this president jacobo
arbenz who was democratically elected
is trying to change things he wants to
take land that united fruit owns but
isn't using and redistribute it to poor
guatemalans he's sort of doing like a
robin hood thing trying to like lift
poor guatemalans out of poverty but of
course united fruit didn't like this but
instead of engaging directly with the
guatemalan government united fruit goes
to the white house and says those magic
words again communism united fruit then
hired this pr magician who happened to
be sigmund freud's nephew and he worked
with news agencies to create a bunch of
fake stories that linked arbenz the
president of guatemala to communism
completely fake news
and not just like using that word
lightly like he created a fake
guatemalan newspaper created all these
fake reports and then distributed those
fake newspapers to congress he planted
the seeds in their minds that the united
fruit company were the good guys and
that arbenz the democratically elected
leader needed to go because of communism
it totally worked president eisenhower
the president of the united states
believed all of this
and he sent in the cia to get our bence
out of power to protect the banana
people once again so it's a classic cia
coup they go find a bunch of rebels they
give them money and they train them
rebels rose to oust guatemala's red
infiltrated government they find a
leader who wants to be the next
president that's friendly to the u.s and
eventually they start broadcasting
anti-government propaganda and they turn
guatemalans against their government
with all of this fake news and
propaganda they send the navy in to
block guatemalan waters they send some
bombs onto guatemala city and then
they invade
[Music]
and then with these trained fighters
they go take over the government the
guatemalan army surrenders and the
leader of the rebels becomes the new
president friendly to the united states
and now the banana companies are happy
and they have a guy in power that is
their guy it's like it's like they have
a playbook on how to like mess with
democracies around the world and they
just sort of followed the playbook
they're like oh we did we've done this
before we're going to do it again in
iran in a little bit like this is like
classic classic cia coup by the way this
coup was sort of a death blow to
democracy in guatemala it divided
and destroyed the budding civil society
that has not allowed guatemala to
recover since all because these banana
companies wanted to control the supply
chain these things leave scars major
scars major marks on a country scars
that are still felt today okay let's
switch gears for a second because all of
this sort of banana like coups and
banana republics and massacres is like
horrendous
but during all of this violence and
military invasions and human rights
violations all of this meant that the
united fruit company was getting really
really good at their business they were
sending too many bananas to the united
states there was a ton of banana supply
but demand wasn't rising fast enough the
average american didn't totally know how
to use bananas so the united fruit
company creates this amazing marketing
campaign
[Music]
so now they're paying doctors to write
amazing academic journal articles about
bananas
they cut a deal with kellogg's to like
market the cereal as something that
pairs with bananas which is something i
still do today i cut up my bananas and i
put them in my cereal because of this
campaign they targeted moms with small
children they made recipe books they
even created a guide on how to decorate
with bananas bananas can be served in
many different and many attractive ways
blended with fruits nuts and gelatins
they provide high food value and
nourishment
but their biggest success
was miss chiquita i'm chiquita banana
and i've come to say bananas have to
ripen in a certain way and when they're
flexed with brown and have a golden hue
bananas taste the best and are the best
for you the american public fell in love
with this lady and bananas they had no
idea that these bananas were being
produced and shipped and bought with
blood they just liked how they taste but
isn't that the case with a lot of things
that we all consume every day but
there's one thing that u.s imperialism
and millions of dollars of marketing
cannot control which is
disease
this is the part of the story that i
tell you that the bananas that were all
the rage during the 1900s are not the
bananas that you're eating today
part of united fruit company's efforts
to control everything was standardizing
the genetics of the banana making them
all exactly the same monocultures is
what we call that the problem with
monocultures is that they are like
heaven for a disease
because you don't have to solve the same
puzzle to infect another banana if you
infect one you infect them all and
that's exactly what happened
panama disease was a fungus that came in
and destroyed banana plantations the
banana supply in the u.s shrank rapidly
and there was even a hit song about the
banana shortage
[Music]
the banana that they had been using the
one that was getting really popular in
the u.s was called the grow michelle or
the big mike banana but it was now
completely getting ravaged by disease so
these banana companies are freaking out
they're like we are done like we've
built this entire empire and this
disease is gonna wipe us out so they
started to scramble to find another
banana it turns out there's like a
thousand types of bananas out there
there's like red ones and blue ones and
like teal ones i mean a blue banana i
feel like i have to eat a blue banana at
some point in my life but here's the
problem us americans we buy our food
kind of with our eyes first we're just
like it needs to look good and so these
companies realize that they couldn't
send a blue banana to the united states
they needed a banana that looked similar
yellow sweet and seedless so that they
could keep selling to americans who
hopefully wouldn't notice the switch
enter
our friend the cavendish banana
[Music]
like i said in the beginning this banana
was invented by a british guy who was
tinkering with banana seeds in this
amazing looking house in northern
england and after years of playing
around with the genetics the plant
finally flowered and popped out this big
beautiful yellow banana
and so he named it after the duke
william cavendish so now here's the sad
part the grow michelle the one that had
caught on that was like the big hit in
america was a way better banana is a way
better banana it is sweeter it's more
durable and it's just overall a better
banana compared to the cavendish in fact
the artificial banana flavor that we
have in our candies like blaffy taffy
comes from the original grow michelle
not from the cavendish but the grow me
shell was getting destroyed by this
disease and the cavendish was luckily
resistant to the disease so the dictator
banana companies made the switch and
hoped that the people wouldn't care or
notice as long as they looked the same
and guess what it totally worked they
quietly switched out the banana to the
new cavendish and people just kept
buying bananas i mean i can't believe
that there is a better banana out there
that i have not tasted i wonder if i can
get my hands on one
[Music]
bananas the grommy shell banana still
exists it's just a select few people on
this planet still grow it and i found a
farm that sent me a few
i'm gonna try this thing
grow michelle let's do this
[Music]
what a beautiful banana
wow i mean i'm obviously primed to like
this more so i don't know if i'm really
liking it more but it's definitely a
better banana right now in my mind
slightly different color it's got this
like burgundy vibe going on it's sweeter
i like the texture more i think this is
a better banana too bad this thing got
completely wiped out
by a disease okay so let's get up to
speed before we finish this story off
because the last part of it is quite
interesting and applies to
our modern day to summarize bananas came
to the u.s predatory companies invaded
whole countries to help the us exploit
them for bananas while using amazing
marketing to keep demand up and because
of this panama disease they had to
switch to the inferior cavendish banana
so where do we go from here united fruit
eventually rebranded to chiquita they're
still doing some pretty shady stuff like
paying millions of dollars to terrorist
death squads and getting sued by workers
who have become sterile after handling
pesticides
banana companies will probably always do
this because the other thing that
remains is that bananas are still soft
and spoil quickly and grow in far away
places from where you eat them so the
entire supply chain needs to be
controlled and the other thing that
hasn't changed is that the new banana is
genetically optimized so that every
banana is exactly the same so it fits
perfectly into these boxes into these
crates onto these ships into these
supermarkets but guess what
there's another disease the panama
disease the one that wiped out the grow
michel it's back and it's mutated and
it's coming for the cavendish and what's
tricky about these diseases is there's
no way to detect them before they arrive
before it's too late it just quietly
kills the banana trees and makes it
impossible to ever grow there again you
have to burn the entire plantation this
is already happening in the philippines
which is the second largest exporter of
bananas the disease has devastated the
land and the banana economy it's making
its way through asia okay but asia's
like super far away and it's like
there's a whole ocean in between it's
like all our bananas come from latin
america wrong in 2019 it was detected in
colombia and in april of this year just
a few months ago the disease was found
in peru
right next to ecuador which is the
largest exporter of bananas that come to
the us it's coming for your bananas so
everyone's on high alert and bananas as
we know them might be doomed so now
we're seeing history kind of repeat
itself
we're looking at the potential collapse
of a 25 billion dollar industry and
entire economies
which is like hundreds of thousands of
jobs
to me the big problem here the thing
that's repeating itself
is the same problem of united fruit
company going in trying to control every
angle of their production to maximize
profits
when we have companies
that feel emboldened to do whatever it
takes to make the most profit you're
going to get situations like this
whether it is banana massacres in
colombia or a coup in honduras or a
monoculture that gets wiped out by
disease time and time again we try to
engineer our way out of these problems
and we sometimes do but at the end of
the day nature will catch up with us and
as long as we ignore the true costs of
these economies
the cost to people to democracies
to ecologies
we're never actually going to get rid of
these problems okay
thanks for watching
i'm going to eat a cavendish now
so yeah